[Music]
so we are starting a new series called
Elevate where I had a passion to work
with some young Toronto entrepreneurs
people interested in the film business
and connected with a new friend of mine
Anthony carmichel he's in Toronto he's
at film school but he's been a
videographer for8 years two weeks ago we
met up and I just like meeting up with
creative people to see what are they
doing how can we roll
together this guy loves filming but he
loves mentoring as well well and so we
came up with this idea where we're going
to get two young ambitious videographers
up and coming in the city they're going
to follow me around for 6 months we're
going to work with them we're going to
bring you guys behind the scenes we kind
of watch the series this is our first
time meeting these guys we got Tito and
Jamal we're going to learn about their
story we're going to get to know them
and see where this whole thing goes I'm
working with this uh a program called
Elevate agency I'm Tito chob Barry so
basically me uh I was a lot into ENT
entrepreneurship so they're coming here
the first time meeting me did you guys
knew about the channel I I first got to
know the channel true Anthony okay so
Anthony comes to you like what two weeks
ago and says hey we've got this
opportunity Anthony actually created a
group with a whole bunch of film
students and we started talking about uh
some uh a film about Elevate program and
uh that was when I got to know and then
he sent uh he sent a list of exactly
what he want from us with the with the
notes and he add you EV come
it was really um it was really
attractive to me when I saw it but I
wasn't sure if I want to do it or not
until later on when he actually asked me
I was like yeah I'm really interested
because I do have somebody I'm talking
to about starting my own business plan
and everything before so when I saw that
thing I was like wow this is really
impressive and then he had all of these
things I'm like okay I'll be down to try
this out so that was how I got to know
you and then I did my research I went to
your Instagram and I went to your
YouTube I was like whoa I really want to
get into this because those are the type
of people I need to you know be learned
from in my life and everything cool man
okay how about you yeah so basically me
uh I was a lot into um entrepreneurship
I with Tony Robbins okay wrote a lot of
books from Tony Robbins and so yes when
Anthony uh showed me this opportunity I
was definitely really into it right away
and uh yeah and I already knew about you
I already knew about you I watch a few
of your video on YouTube also so yeah so
talk about taking your shot so tell Tony
was the first big you know Tony Robbins
I do so Tony was the first big interview
that I had on my channel like where I
was going to interview somebody and he's
been on three or four times now we've
done interviews with him but he was the
first one that I got and he was
promoting one of his books I think and
he doesn't like to do online like he
rather do in person especially back in
the day okay and uh I was helping his
YouTube Team a little bit with their
Channel and they said okay Tony doesn't
do a lot of online he only doing like
three or four and we got you to be one
of the people like oh my God this is
great like yes okay like we've made it
we got Tony R my first big I've done
interviews but they're all little ones
Tony R is gonna be great the like two
weeks leading up to it I'm a I'm a
stress ball like nervous
wreck trying to memorize my script dud
what am I going to do what am I going to
say I what questions it's Tony Robbins
but I knew him like knew of him for you
know decades right I mean maybe not
decades itbe a decade at that point then
we get to the day of and I'm like I
can't focus on anything CU all I can
think about I don't even know what ever
happened else during the day because I'm
only so stressed out about going to go
I'm GNA I'm going to interview Tony
Robbins Guy this is great and uh just
before the interview his team messages
like Tony can't do it like something
happened and he's not going to be able
to to do it wow and uh one is like
immediate like oh man like yeah the only
the only thing worse than all the stress
of the meeting was it not happening and
then the let down like but I never like
got a chance to take my shot yeah so
it's like saying yes to the
opportunities but then I stayed in touch
with this team I kept helping them kept
giving them advice just stayed in touch
and the next time he had his uh new book
coming up uh again they said okay you
know you've been so helpful we're going
to book one of the spots for you but
that took another year to get so it's
like a year it took so long to get the
first one and then it got canceled the
day of and nothing like stuff happens
too right like I'm here suppos with you
guys something happens and I get called
away you know that stuff can happen so I
don't blame him for anything but um
another year of like working on it
working on it maintaining a relationship
and then boom then we land the interview
that one has almost 2 million views now
on the channel and then he's come on a
couple times since so it's just and that
creates opportunities like that led to
oh Tony came on okay I'll come on and
I'll come on and led to all these bigger
names want to come on the channel as
well so it's like just saying yes to the
opportunity you never know even if it's
a total failure even if it's like you
come here and you're super nervous and
I'm an idiot you know I like I hate Tito
like the name is stupid and I don't like
anybody named Tito right and then you go
home like even if I suck just the fact
that you did it and you said yeah like
the the willingness to fail is the
inspiration so you can go off and do it
again right so the fact that you're if
you're nervous about it it's like a good
sign it's like you run into it as
opposed to back in way regardless of how
the outcome is right thanks anyway so
what's on the sheet you bring the sheet
here what's in here uh so it's a
business plan for integrated Fitness
lifestyle and Technology platform okay
that I'm planning to uh bring to life
okay you know um as I'm a film student
right now I don't have the opportunity
to really walk to really do a lot of
things like that so I've been on working
on this for like a long time now before
I quit my old job and pick up this
school one of the biggest reason I took
this schools because I'm judging I mean
for me right now I love Fitness in
general so I reach judging from you
right now what you mean like just
looking at you he like look at how good
I look you guys know I'm in the fitness
that's basically what exactly exactly so
you guys can see how you guys can see
how I look right now but still um you
guys can see how I look right it's like
are we're going to see like Slimmer and
Slimmer clothes as we go on like by by
month three is going to be topless and
yeah okay perfect so yeah um I've had a
lot of people uh always asking me like
what do you do Tito here for example
he's always try been always trying to
ask me like hey man how do I I want to
get into the gym what do you do what do
you eat what do you all of that so I get
this type of question at least five 10
times a day sometimes I have people
asking and all of that so I was like you
know what I reached this stage that I
already know exactly what I'm doing you
know I have my pass and training license
I have all of these things so the plan
now for me I'm working with this uh a
program called Elevate agency okay
Elevate Elevate yeah okay
so they they actually going to help me
create an online platform and all of
those things like that so for me to
actually know the how to walk my way
around in the internet how to really you
know put out my YouTube channel because
those are going to be the things I'm
going to be using to get clients and to
train people and to have all of those
things so that's why I reach out to uh
someone it's uh she's a marketer a
marketing agenc she works with like top
500 companies so I gave all these ideas
that I have and everything so which is
why how we created all this thing and it
was right at that time that Anthony
after that program which has the same
name as the agency I was almost working
for so he almost felt like a calling to
me and then like you know I'm going to
get all this down I got all this down
and show it to Anthony when I first got
it as well and then I was like oh okay
we're coming to this meeting I need to
have this out there and then I'm going
to show you to you so it pretty much as
a I going to create something with the
the content creation up uh I I don't
know if I can explain all of this right
now but it might take some time but I
also want to do something with like a
passer grow and Technology integration
also um one other thing I'm working
constantly on every single day cuz I
work out every single day so one thing
I'm working on is uh one thing I'm
working on is uh is a Guinness know if
if you didn't know if you can't tell
hold on if you can't tell guys I work
out every single day yeah I'm giveing
you I know I know it's okay it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's it's helping
it's helping with the nervousness and
everything so that's actually good so um
I'm working on a particular goal to
break a a Guinness World Record okay so
it's the most pull up in 24 hours I
train every single day I do pull-ups
every single day I've already broken two
gr World rockers real yeah I'd like to
see that which one was it we did the
world's largest uh mentoring uh session
yeah and then we did a uh we did the
world's largest QR code wow to support
entrepreneurs from disadvantaged areas
how does the K code work like we went so
this's this this's this program here in
Toronto yeah that uh takes people from
Jane Finch I don't if you know Jane
Finch it's not the best neighborhood I
leave they like my oh perfect there you
go okay so I mean not the best
neighborhood and uh a lot of crime Etc
and so they take kids who are not from
the best backgrounds and don't
necessarily have mentors and uh put them
into an entrepreneurship programs like
the path off the street is to start your
own business yes and so I was a guest
trainer for the it's a nonprofit I was a
guest trainer there and then the raise
money they uh created the world's
largest QR code and we went to a soccer
field and we uh there's a whole bunch of
volunteers and some of us had a white
cardboard and some of us had a black
cardboard and we' stand and we we held
the thing up and then a plane came
overhead and took a picture of us and we
are the QR code of pixels of and then if
you took a picture of it you could
donate to the program nice nice nice
nice nice nice that's really good that's
really good I remember when I was in J
Finch uh when I first moved to canada8
years ago it was one of the rough First
Neighborhood for sure that's like 100%
every single day I either you know a
gunshot or something is going on so
that's something really good amazing I'm
sure it must have helped a lot of kid so
going back to what I was talking about
um you do I'm sure everybody here know
David gagin is yeah it was one of the
first very first person to break uh the
most pull-ups in David gokin pull up
actually somebody already broke it okay
so somebody already broke his but nobody
knows who that guy is the guy I don't
know why you how many do you need to do
um I need to be 8,000 8,000 in how long
24 hours 20 8,000 pull-ups in 24 hours
hours yes David ggins when he did his
own was like um 4,000 that's weak sauce
dude 4,000 Jesus 4,000 but still nobody
thought it was possible you know when he
did it and then there cames a kid from
Australia did 8000 000 okay so now I'm
trying to go for 10K yeah and how many
can you do right now how many can I do
in in 24 hours I can do 1,000 in 24
hours I've been training for that you
got a you got a you got a ways to go oh
yeah oh with this thing if I'm actually
um not even actually this is this type
of thing that I'm going to have a coach
for I'm going to have like nutrition for
so this it's not something that's not
it's not impossible you know you just
have to like plan it out and those are
the things I'm trying to go how many
pull-ups can you do t uh I think around
four or five yeah hey go that's a start
no it's xtraining it can get there
anybody can do I don't even know I don't
you know you said something interesting
like you are asking him for advice on
like Fitness and getting to the gym and
all that we
honestly and if you're going to start a
business around this the most important
thing is just
start like you don't even need his
advice on what weights to lift and what
exercises to do you just need to get in
the gym and do something like if you
show up in the gym for half an hour and
you did anything you took any random
machine and you started working on it
and you just started doing push-ups or
pull-ups or whatever it may not be the
best optimized program but this is a
challenge at the beginning of anything
like video whatever is you make it way
bigger than it is like oh I can't start
until I have like the perfect program so
I got to talk to Jamal and then you give
him some crazy program like it doesn't
matter you just go to the gym and do
something true like how do you learn to
be a videographer well you pick up the
camera and you start you pick up your
cell phone and you start messing around
with the there's a lot of settings on
your phone to make a pretty good video
yes right so a lot of it is the
motivation and a great trainer is really
just a psychologist it's like getting
him into the gym to go do something
together is way more valuable than
giving a meal plan and prep and here's
your next four months of workouts
because he's going to do the first one
and then like not do anything else
afterwards right okay it all starts it
all starts from you uh that mixes when
you say just go in the gym I have a very
video a video that I've been keeping
away from online why it's because it was
my very first time in the gym and I saw
that video of me picking up the Dum why
is it not online I was like this yeah
the way it looks why can't you put it
online because I'm on a I'm on a stage
of rebranding right now my God page to
actually I'm those are the videos I'm
actually going to start putting out to
show people that it's possible cuz when
people see me these days all they say is
like I was talking to uh s yesterday she
was like when she see my Instagram when
she sees the stuff I'm doing she say she
get so intimidated by that so I want to
start with the thing that I'm showing my
past videos of me looking so awkward why
is it not online but upload it today
okay I'm going to I'm going to these are
the things I want to start you know
learning from you you say you just got
to start Los the type of thing that's
why your brand your brand is you yes not
some like perfect version of right so
showing the journey you look at Goggins
you know you look at his story the thing
that's inspirational is that he was this
he shows pictures of him being this fat
yeah guy who's like a cockroach inspect
sprayer who failed out of all these
programs right and not the smartest guy
smartest student and what he became not
just that he's perfect right now true
true true so the journey is the whole
thing that now I mean the fact that you
are can already do a thousand most
people can't do a thousand pull-ups in
24 hours right so you're already are in
the top whatever half a percent yeah
even though it's nowhere close to you
still have to get eight times better
right yes but you're already in the top
half percent so how did you get there
and showing the journey and showing what
you what you struggled with and showing
how you you couldn't even pick up a 20
lb dumbbell or whatever yeah that's
that's what will connect people to you
much more than anything else and that's
those are the things I was trying to
learn myself like re-educate myself when
I took the break from social media CU
all I was doing when I back then was
like showing the perfect form showing
all this perfect perfect thing that's
but you don't you don't reeducate
Yourself by thinking about it yes you
you post you post you do it exactly
exactly so these are the things that I
that's some good homework today yeah you
post that post post the week week Ling
Jamal trying to lift 20 pounds okay all
right okay looks like I got an homework
let's let's do it y that's some easy
homework all right I don't know if you
want to talk to Tony cuz I have
something else I want to say Tony
Anthony now you
Tony dude you going to with this guy
Tony Robbins is my mind now somebody I
listen to as well do you know how giant
Tony Robbins is I know I know Tony has
now invited me to his events and stuff
took some pictures backstage and
everything and he's like I'm 6'1 he's
like giant above me his hand is huge so
anyway Tito
Tito what about you man why why film
school so yes to explain that I will
have to like add a little bit of context
so let me just introduce myself myself
real quick so yes I'm Tito chob Berry uh
I was born in the US came to montal when
I was 1 years old okay uh then I left
marro when I was 10 years old and I went
to the north of France okay in Lil and
then I spent one year in Lil then I went
to Africa in Guinea West Africa okay
where I spent two years then I went back
to France holy C north of this is all
for school or parents moving par yeah
parents moving basically okay for jobs
yeah B so you bounced around like crazy
yeah they were stressing for theel
searching for a way to get money right
yeah my father was an entrepreneur okay
so yeah he didn't really have a job he
was just searching for ways to make
money so yeah traveled a lot is he still
around you said was he's still uh now
he's in Africa so yeah he's not in here
in Canada so yes uh and I came back when
I finished high school I came back to
Montreal in 2020 okay and yeah this is
was this was the weirdest part of my
life cuz I was studying econ ecomics but
I don't know I was just feeling like I'm
just doing it to give a diploma to my
parents and trying to find a job so I
can pay bills and be an adult right MH
so I was just thinking I was in my room
and I was just thinking like is that
really what you want to do with your
life and I was just like so yes in
January 2023 actually I decid to drop
out of economics and I was just like let
me just school to film school to improve
my English first cuz I'm a French
speaker okay yeah and uh yeah that's it
so now here I am I would say that what
drived me to to want to become a
filmmaker was really one movie it was uh
one movie from spele Malcolm X okay when
I watched that movie I was really I was
freaking out I was like how did he did
that this movie really inspired me and
because what was it about it because of
the way that he he was able to explain
the feelings that people was like when I
watched this movie I was really feeling
like I was there you know I felt like I
was living with the black black peners
you know so yeah basically yeah this
movie was really inspiring for me and
you like the story or you like the way
that spikey told the story the story and
the cinematography of the the movie also
got okay have you seen uh what's
it uh something Harlem I forget the name
it's a great show it's about Malcolm X
like it was a they did a two or three
season three seasons Godfather of Harlem
Bumpy Johnson Bumpy Johnson yeah have
you seen it yeah I liked it it's I mean
because Malcolm X is is like the second
character Bumpy Johnson is a gangster
and he's the main character and Malcolm
X is the secondary character did you
watch all three seasons yeah I watched
the whole when they changed the Malcolm
X character it just wasn't as good like
season one Malcolm X was so good and
then they changed him it just wasn't as
good that's the thing was
acting every character brings to their
their role to life in a different way
it's like the the different Joker
that that played in Batman um what's the
one that passed away e sler he was the
best Joker of all the jokers in my
opinion but some people might differ but
he committed to that role like like you
said it made you feel like that Malcolm
X movie made you feel like it was real
there his Joker made me feel like I was
there and I was that was the real his
real personality even though he was an
actor so when you change out an actor
they it's like uh Denzel Washington when
he when he acts I don't care what he
does he can do no wrong M he the the
emotion the the commitment he brings to
a role is like no other and that's that
that's I guess what you were trying to
conve in in a more I went to University
for economics I graduated with an
economics degree okay uh I mean I like
I've used it ever since I don't think it
was for me but yeah also I I when I was
young I was reading a lot of comic books
so this is really related to what I I'm
trying favorite book Marvel which one
Marvel I read uh Captain America a lot
Iron Man a lot uh a lot of uh I read
black panther
actually because of my older brother and
uh I think that's Superman okay lot of
Superman Batman also okay so all of them
love all the big all the superheroes you
know was really into it and uh so when I
was watching the Marvel movie and seeing
how the story the identity of it is
adapted this was really like I was
really like this is what I want to do so
basically what I'm trying to do with uh
the company that I want to launch is uh
I want to write comic books cuz I have a
lot of script basically in my during my
time usually I'll just write script I
have a lot of script and I just want to
like adapt them to a YouTube channel
okay so I can uh get a lot of views
hopefully and uh
show people uh basically every emotions
that I can I would like to talk about
War I would like to talk about love I
would like to talk about religion I
would like to talk about everything
through this actually who are three
people that you'd want to interview to
talk about this kind of stuff I'll say
spele Michael B Jordan okay a lot
Michael B Jordan and uh the last one I
will say Christopher Nolan for sure okay
Christopher Nolan for sure okay how
about you Jamal David gogins okay um
Tony Edelman who's Tony Edelman uh he's
the one he the one that wrote the book
um Noom is the nice guy okay what does
he do he's an author but he's got to be
more he's an author yeah just an author
yeah he just writes books no uh he does
books uh he's also like
um uh he helps men you know he's a coach
yeah sort of like a coach you know an
online coach he wrotes book uh his book
is one actually one of the top best
selling you know New York Times so um
okay uh I wasn't really in a rough place
when I when I got one of his books you
know I really didn't think uh much about
books cuz I never really read all I was
in a really really rough place and
somebody hey check out this book take
this book I just got out of a
relationship and I pick up the book and
everything in that book just resonated
with me so it's one of the reason it's
is uh it's another reason why I want to
talk to the guy in person and learn you
know it's always good to talk to people
in person because you can feel it more
than when I read a book but the book did
help so it's going to be one of the
person uh one person I want to uh
interview another person I would like to
interview is going to be the last one
you got three yeah the last one that
one's into Morgan Freeman if that's
possible oh Morgan Freeman okay
interesting why Morgan Freeman he's uh
he's a great actor yeah and uh I love
the way that when he talks yeah you can
he almost it's like it almost get your
attention with the way he talks like not
just the attention he can feel
everything he almost put you inside the
story okay so that's one thing I would
like to Lear he's the voice man he's the
voice of everything exactly Hey where's
Anthony I can't even see there well
who's keeping track of homework are you
keeping track of homework do these guys
have to keep track of homework you
keeping track of homework I want to
create a plan where over the six months
they're they're trying to get these guys
interviewed on my channel if he can yeah
why
not definitely yeah so get you're going
to reach out we'll put it on the channel
I mean that would be awesome that would
be awesome I mean nobody's unreachable
right I mean they they we've had big
names on the channel um and because we
have so many
subscribers we don't uh go is probably
the most like closest to what I
currently do who's the biggest comp
Matthew MCC I had on the Chanel I did an
interview with Matthew MCC so like in
the acting world you can point to that
and said hey I haven't had Matthew MCC
on but it's just about figuring out the
like who's the person to connect who's
their PR person to connect the dots and
then if they're in promotion mode gogin
is hard cuz when he's not promoting
something he's like he doesn't care
enough about media I feel like I'll get
along with gaggin in a way because he
always he has these sort of like traines
that he does with
people you do a pull-up competition
against gogin I feel like that who can
do more pull-ups in an hour me and gogin
I can do more you think so yes I think
so this is not this is not for
confidence or anything like that what do
you think this is the ability is he is
he okay so when we came you're being
recorded yeah hold on hold on hold on I
can't I can't that's going to get him
the show so so when we came when we came
here it was like all this big setup
because Anthony you know was all talk
about I about all this gear yada yada
yada and like I don't know if this guy
is is full of it or and so he actually
has all the gear here right okay so you
know Anthony kind of now showed up to
you guys and he has all the stuff so
when he's saying that he he can beat
gogin in a pull-up comp say one hour of
pull-ups do you think he actually you
think you think he's all talk you think
he's going to beat goggin it's a it's a
big bet what do you but what do you
think what do you what's where's your
money Anthony I I I believe whatever you
believe is
true this guy's such a poop out dude
he's such a what kind I answer is
that oh let's see let's see where's your
who's your money on an hour of pull-ups
goggin
Jamal one hour not not this 24-hour
thing because it go
oh my God we can't get an answer out of
this guy let's go age versus experience
okay so weigh it weigh it let's go
mental calculation experience of doing
it you have the youth in you so I don't
know I have the experience as
well no I've reach you got to pop out a
little more like I
got I'll be counting my pull-ups okay
well look right into that camera over
there tell I've done since I've been
doing pull-ups for the past uh 12 years
I've done 15,000 Pull-Ups okay in 12
years you've done 15,000 pull-ups total
yes and you need to do 8,000 in 24 hours
24 hours I do 100 to 200 pull-ups every
day training for this particular record
I'm putting my money on you bro I got
you I mean could was it so hard for
anything to say that it's so hard anony
anony hasn't work out I mean Tito hasn't
work out with me but you work out with
me he's just not he's not betting on you
it's like I can't put money on you no
he's not putting money that's that's
fine he put money on you in in Camp Goin
so okay
good that's completely fine that's
completely fine good we got a story line
Brewing here perfect that is fine that
is f goggin and I let's do it so like
everybody is reachable right it's just
about the path through and and what is
the thing that they're trying to promote
or get eyeballs on right so you know if
we've got six months together that's you
can hit them I have a question you said
everybody's reachable but doesn't it
doesn't it depend on the quality of your
page thing like that doesn't it have
like you can put on on my channel oh
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah well the I mean
yes of course it's going to be a lot
harder for you to go and do it on your
own right not that you couldn't but it
may not happen within you know six
months but yes we'll interview them I
mean I'll be part of it but it'll be on
my channel so you get to use my channel
as the the the reason to go reach out
thanks appreciate that but it's also you
got to do the work like they're not just
going to respond to a single Instagram
DM and say yeah let me I'm in right it's
like who's the pr person what are they
promoting look at their bio in their
Instagram and see what thing they're
promoting right now that they want
eyeballs on like Matthew mccon came on
my channel because he was promoting his
book mostly I have entrepreneurs on
right I mean I I didn't know much about
Matthew mccon before he came on he's an
actor I know his name obviously but I
don't know his story I don't know what
he but he was getting into his book so
he wanted to launch it uh you guys
actually have like the stories of why I
asked you those you didn't just pick
three random people you know you don't
want spike Leon CU I don't know he's
like him he's he's the director right
like it means the story means something
right so one thing I always love doing
is creating like is creating art and and
creating opportunities right in
elevating you guys right so if we can if
we can get Lee or goggin or whoever
I spoke with goggin on
stage uh in
Whistler uh it was my last event before
the whole shutdown and that was between
goggin and um pton Manning who's a one
of the best football players of all time
Pon Manning yeah I did um it's so like
everybody is reachable and so it's part
of the but not if you don't put the
effort put in the effort in right like
well how do you do it just back to the
gy analogy right well how do you do it
well you start you start doing some
stuff and then you look at how other
people have made connections and reached
out to people and then you find the path
through like those are not impossible
names you know if you
said if you said the the rock or
something be a lot like right now is
going to be hard if you if you're taking
people who are like white hot in the
moment right now where there's lots of
attention on them it's going to be a lot
harder yes but all six of those names
are not they're not white hot right now
they're still big names but it's
definitely achievable you know i'
definitely like to train with gogins
100% he has this uh program that runs
with like people look into where does he
live no clue we got to find out yes
right like this is part of the work
homework yeah homework likeor where does
he live who does he hang out with who
does he follow on social media nobody
that spele is teaching at the NYU right
now
great but like you just start making it
okay so he teaches at NYU okay so who's
it who else is at NYU or how do we make
who does he follow on Instagram or who
does he follow on Twitter you know and
you start making the connections you go
to his book page who's the publisher
who's the pr person connected to it
right you just start making connections
to try to make it
happen right like so here's an example
even if you don't have me like I'm going
to put you up it may be great for me you
know I mean goggin sure I've never
approached any of these guys because it
wasn't important enough for me right I
mean the second guy I didn't even know
who who he was what's his name again
Tony Edelman Tony Edelman yes maybe we
did a video on him I don't know but
anyway but now I want him on because you
want him on so for my first
book uh I really wanted to get Jessica
Alba in in the book cuz we were writing
that book U it was called your one
and it's helping people figure out the
most important one word core value and
we probably have copies here somewhere
Alex we have copies here of your one
word so Jessica ala started a company
called The Honest Company M that's worth
hundreds of millions maybe it's a
billion other company I don't know but
hundreds of Millions for sure so I
really wanted Jessica Alber to be in my
book so I I wrote to them I don't know
Jessica Alber I don't know anybody in
the acting world I'm I'm from the
entrepreneur land person development I
don't know any of these people so I
worked my way through and I got to the
right person inside the Honest Company
and I said hey uh I'm writing this book
penguin Random House talking about one
word you have a company off of one word
I love to interview for the book and
they said
no I have I got a YouTube channel I've
got all this stuff that said no like
just and it's every know is really just
like I'm not now right they're like busy
with some launch they don't care about
this thing right now so okay my YouTube
channel at the time was a lot smaller
and so it wasn't enough to get the yes
so then I wrote to TechCrunch I don't
even know Tech crunch but at the time
was the biggest
technology
entrepreneurship blog in the world and I
don't I didn't know anybody there but I
wrote to the U the main editor and I
said hey if I could get Jessica
Alba as an interview would you publish
it on
TechCrunch and they said hey if you can
get here talking about like women in
technology we we would publish it so now
like okay okay I want I'm going to I'll
use part of the interview to go to Tech
Crunch and I'll use part of the
interview to go to my book then I write
back to Honest Company like hey I've got
TechCrunch who wants to publish the
interview if we could talk about like
women in technology I've got Tech crunch
who's willing to publish this thing
right and I just found the guy's email
on the website I got no connections
right and um they said yes but we ran
out of time for the publishing Divine so
like I had to get my book in and
submitted before we had time to go do
the interview but given another like 6
months we would have made that whole
thing happen so like even like I'm
giving you my platform to go and do the
Outreach to make these connections but
even if you didn't have me it's just
thinking about what does Spike Lee want
right now and then how do I connect him
to something if I can connect Jessica
Alba to
TechCrunch because she's an she's an
actress who's an entrepreneur but she's
seen as an actress so if she gets into
Tech crunch that's a big deal because
now it's like she's seen as an Entre
entrepreneur so she wants to have the
entrepreneurship so you're saying it has
to be a win-win situation yeah but like
you create the win-win I'm helping you
create the win but you don't even need
me to make those things happen you just
have to find something that they care
about and connect them to something else
right so it's like they're not now the
timing may not be right but nobody is
Out Of Reach if you really want to make
something happen you just got to figure
out what do they care about like what
does Spike Le care about right now I
have no idea like I got zero clue I mean
I I probably watched a movie or two of
his but I don't know his story
deeply but what is he promoting like but
you could find out tonight what Le
cares about what's he posting about on
Twitter what's he posting about on
Instagram homework yeah but that's super
easy right like where does he live I
have no idea well find out right I mean
it's like it's not that hard to know
somebody's world and then when you see
something they care about even if you
don't have a connection to help him with
that find somebody else who has a
connection and then just make them come
together and you're a part of it like
how do you elevate this is a world that
we just aren't trained to think like
this right but it's all possible if you
want true true you can get to anybody if
you really want now again the hotter the
flame the harder it is to reach that
person but the names that you're saying
and we've already had on they they reach
with Tony especially it's reachable
there's a website that you can actually
reach out to him cuz he's a coach so he
reads you can get him on the that one is
for sure yeah 100% and uh as for ggins
he's 100% I think he's
reachable one thing lots of paths and
who's the third person uh Morgan Freeman
Morgan Freeman but like what's Morgan
doing right now I have no idea what's
Michael B Jordan doing right now I don't
know no idea like if they're on set
filming right now it's going to be hard
for him to take time out to do this
right and that's cool it's fine like
it's un but that's why it's just you
give somebody enough time
and then he's going to be in promotion
mode and like oh I get to talk to this
big channel right the MCC video I don't
know it's got over a million views on it
right just the the right time so who's
the agent for Michael B Jordan to be
able to figure out I don't know I don't
know if he's filming right now if he's
chilling right now whatever but if
you're on it you watch his Instagram
stories yeah is he filming or is he like
chilling yeah but whenever I reach this
point where I'm thinking um I'm just
like in my in my room and I'm thinking
okay I should reach to this people to
this guy mhm where should I start cuz
I'm I'm just taking like should I watch
his followers should I go on LinkedIn
should I go on Twitter should I but it's
the same thing as the gym should you go
to the gym okay and you mess up makes
sense like you go to the gym and you you
start lifting weights I mean hopefully
you don't hurt yourself right don't do
something so stupid that you hurt
yourself but it's like everybody's
trying to find the perfect plan and it's
great to always have a mentor to help
and guide but you can't let the lack of
a perfect plan prevent you from taking
action so what where people struggle
with the gym for example this is an
easier example to understand it's like
okay well I'm going to go you go talk to
Jamal he's like okay and Jamal tells you
to do okay here's what you got to do you
got to do 10 push-ups a day you got to
do 10 pull-ups a day you got he gives
you a plan and then you talk to somebody
else and they tell you to do something
else well now who's right and then you
look up online like oh you're supposed
to do CrossFit don't go to the gym do
CrossFit it's like okay well which
CrossFit and where's like the local
CrossFit and then as you get in the
CrossFit and research and he like but
maybe I should do I need to work on my
flexibility like maybe I should throw a
little yoga in there or something and we
just like think think think think think
and all of a sudden it's like 3 months
later 6 months later 3 years later and
you still haven't done anything right so
the best thing it doesn't mean have zero
plan but the best thing is you go to the
gym and you start working out even just
showing up to the gym and doing your
best and feeling like an idiot cuz all
the these guys are doing you got this
guy like this and like doing a thousand
push-ups or pull-ups or whatever see
even as I did this like this is not a
push-up right you go there and like guys
like him look awesome and you feel like
even worse definitely just like I don't
even know how any of this stuff works
and I'm too embarrassed to ask how to
use this machine but it looks fancy so
I'm just going to leave or I'm just
going to watch or right but you just go
off and start doing so it's not that you
can't learn there's lots of ways on how
to get to bigname people and I'm giving
you a much easier path to say hey use my
channel but don't let
any like research be in the way of you
just starting so should you start on
LinkedIn sure should you start on
Twitter sure should you start by looking
at NYU stuff sure and just like when you
go to the gym if you first walk into the
gym and you do 14 push-ups what do those
14 push-ups do for your body nothing
right like it's 14 push-ups zero it's
not going to get you're not going to go
home and now you've got muscles right
it's a process it's a process but if but
the fact that you just started if you
went back okay the next day you did 14
and then 15 and then 15 and then now if
you keep doing that every day you're
going to start to get some muscles even
if your Technique is terrible and your
form is off and you just you're just
trying to do any kind of push-up you can
then he can come in and say oh my god
dude your push-ups suck like fix your
angle fix your hands but at least you've
been putting in the effort right so the
same thing and again it's not that you
have zero plan but you the most
important thing is just starting just
start building momentum okay
about momentum I saw that on your page
and I wanted to ask you can you please
like explain it more in details cuz I
didn't really get like what it is so do
we have a Alex do we have a momentum
here do we have copies momentum serve
okay so that's my latest book momentum
but the idea is the only thing you're
missing is momentum okay like you have
idea you have ideas of what you want to
do you you want to get fit you want to
be stronger you want to talk to Spike
Lee you want to whatever like and you've
already done some like you said I don't
want to be in economics anymore to do
some degree so that my parents can be
happy like I need to live my life so I'm
going to drop out and do film school
because I saw a spike L videoa right
like that's that's momentum did you have
a whole game plan worked out not yet you
might have an idea but like you're
starting so most people they struggle
because they're they're creating just
this perfect plan instead of just going
so the first step should not be planning
in my opinion because you get an idea
you get all inspired right it's like oh
my God this is so great this a great
opportunity I'm going to do this but
then you spend all of your best energy
on planning researching and then what
happens the next day you wake up and you
look at your re like I can't do this yes
I'm going to do this I'm going to beat
goggin's record I'm going to you you've
already lost like you talk it's not even
your friends telling you that you suck
it's you telling you that you suck right
and so the best thing you can do when
you have an idea is go do something
immediately about it right so if Anthony
here is saying hey there's this
opportunity to do something with Evan
right yes if if you feel right right
yeah I'm in yes right because then when
it now it's happening like how long ago
was that Anthony two weeks ago so two
weeks ago did he say yes right away oh
yeah okay so great so you did it right
away okay so you said yes right away and
then did you wake up at all in the past
two weeks it's like what the heck did I
do no or even when you're coming here
you're like like nervous I was nervous
but I'm more nervous because of my
English and also because it's a new
phase it's a new phase in my life but uh
I was really excited great I was really
really excited well and that all growth
comes through nervousness and breaking
your comfort zone right you have to shed
a new skin yeah right so the point is
you said yes and you took immediate
action not even knowing how it's going
to work out but you have to come now cuz
if you had all backed out in the past
two weeks Anthony's going to hold you
you told him
right he's dude what are you talking
about you said you're going to come now
you don't want to let him down so when
you can build momentum and start
especially committing to somebody else
then you you we don't always show up for
ourselves but we'll show up for other
people okay true true right so the best
first step isn't strategy and planning
the best first step is to do something
to build moment because the first step
is the hardest step and people will
often take 10 years to take the first
step like how long are you going to talk
about the gym before you just go to the
gym and start doing something and feels
like it's so big but then when you get
there it's like okay this isn't actually
that what was I so scared about
especially day two when you come back he
like okay now I'm not a complete idiot
like to do this again you could do it
way more easily you wouldn't be as nerv
you might still be nervous but not as
nervous it's like okay it wasn't that
bad okay these lights okay cool like
it's not that bad so we we make it this
big thing and so we don't take any kind
of action so when you get an idea let's
just give it a shot and try it which is
the biggest thing for both of you to
work on cuz you're both kind of over
planners so we need to like stop feeding
the planning wolf and feed the like
let's go do it wolf let's just do it
yeah and if you step out the line I'll
tell you like dude I got to I got to do
this but I'd rather do that than you
have these ideas and you're not saying
anything cuz I won't if I don't want to
do it I won't do it but I won't say
you're an idiot man like that's a stupid
that's stupidest thing I ever heard I
love
ideas we've actually added some ideas
before yeah it it won't stuck to me
because he writes scripts a lot and he
says he has some story lines that we
could actually work together on but the
funny thing is we only talk about it
once we never move forward with it I
feel like right at that moment I could
have say all right I'm going to grab my
camera all right show me the script I
could have I'm coming to over I could
have done all of those things but
instead I went back home constantly
worrying oh my god when am I going to do
this when am I going to do that U my
friend over there Andre gave me his
camera I I've recorded a whole lot of
workout videos guess what those videos
are doing I bought every single thing
they're going up this week on Instagram
that's where they're going they're right
there and I'm not using them because
there just that one thing I don't know
why I'm not trying to dip my my food
into into the into that I don't know
putting myself out there I don't know
why I'm not trying to do that but having
this conversation today have helped me a
lot you know well we need to squash that
like in working with me we need to
squash that and cuz I want those ideas I
want you to tell me to do something cuz
you're you're thinking higher than what
I'm you're thinking storyline and
audience and we're trying to craft
something I'm
just I'm just acting on the set M I'm
just in the moment okay so we we'll work
on it it's easy to say yes but then like
an idea comes like oh my God is this a
stupid idea I don't know like you know
like say something you know what's funny
is the stupidest idea to actually go
crazy online these days I don't know
like there almost sometimes like why
does this do so well when this looks
better but sometimes but I don't even
care like I just want to start building
a muscle like you're by by coming up
with an idea and saying something it's
like just going to the gym yeah so we're
just showing up on your your first
Stories won't be great and you're
starting to get to know like if you come
every week to see me Mentor Alex you'll
have a lot more context and a lot more
of a story to be able to tell than if
it's just oneof right so as you spend
more time we'll figure out more things
but ideally for me I'm just living my
life M and you're you're crafting
stories around it now if you really
wanted to do an interview with me we're
going to sit down here at my you know
home office and we're going to you want
to interview me about something cool
that could be a video but I might be
interviewing somebody else or I might be
doing some YouTube content and you see
something it's like okay like let's we
need to turn that piece into a bigger
story and I don't care if the stories
work or not like you it'll it'll
be uh it's like you're learning the
dance yeah and then it'll it'll get
better each one will get better okay so
Anthony did you hear all that yeah so
now for you though Anthony's job is like
to now
turn this into its own series for
Elevate so like in your journey
hopefully the audience is learning and
growing and getting inspired as
well you guys okay yeah so so to turn
this into something bigger Beyond just
the sit down for whatever two hours what
do you want to do anything anything else
or do you need anything else I have some
surprise plans uh cuz no but like for
today for this for today no uh today was
just an introduction to let you guys
kind of get to know each other and I was
going to give them these cuz I want them
to better organize their thoughts so
okay these planners
here so every day I want you guys to
stick to the
planners and try to like Journal
yourself and what you're doing to kind
of like get you in a better position
mentally and spiritually and hopefully
financially and
also these will help you on your quest
to becoming film creators thanks thanks
to zun yeah thanks let's go appreciate
you man Anthony getting some free gear
zun shout out to zun shout out to Z for
the gear but I want you guys on your own
Journey not together it together I mean
we might do some stuff together and
that's up to that's up to Anthony for
kind of how to handle this but I think
it's it's good for you guys to be on
your own Journey as we go through it
like I want your creative ideas to come
out we're doing it together but there's
also the growth of like hey you're
you're solo and like you're in charge
you guys both have different visions of
how you see your futures right true true
and I have different tasks for both
individuals so if we're looking at this
as an example this is for now for all of
you so for Anthony kind of leading this
and then for you guys to lead your own
you know content as we start creating I
wouldn't want to do a show where it's
just this so like if I'm Anthony I'd be
thinking okay I want to I would go get
your opinions afterwards like I want to
I would get you walking back to the car
and say what did you think about that
because I wanted I want people to follow
whatever Anthony Sees In The Narrative
now you might have stepped out and
missed a little bit or was talking or
whatever but like in general crafting a
narrative around you guys you're not
thinking Story right you're just talking
to me
he should be thinking Story of like how
do we get people to be inspired by Tito
and that like in seeing Tito I see
myself and I'm cheering for Tito because
I'm really cheering for me I want him to
make it because I want to make it right
how do we better tell that story and so
ideally Anthony is thinking about that
and then afterwards there's something
else that happens whether he wants my
opinion whether I have a voiceover I
need to record whether he pulls you
aside and says like hey how was that
what do you think you're excited you're
scared whatever because I don't want it
to to just be this mhm right so now this
is a fine first step and maybe there's
nothing else kind of planned afterwards
but I would much rather have a a story
told in each video than the perfect
Framing and lighting and everything else
more running gun
yes yeah I mean it's I I operate best in
run a gun but I don't mind doing form
this is this is great too I didn't
figure it would be much of these it this
was just for the introduction but even
inside of this what where is the lesson
that we're then pulling out for people
to watch and get inspired so that I
should leave here cheering these guys on
and then future episodes might I don't
know again this I'm not thinking about
this but if it's if an episode's
dedicated just to Tito or one just to
Jamal or it's always both of them and
it's part one part two I don't know
whatever right again you tell me what
you want to do but I need to leave this
video feeling like I'm cheering these
guys on I want to see them succeed
because if they have their come up then
I might have mine so have we done that
with just the interview maybe but like
what else could we do outside that then
makes that video be a home run yeah
that's what I need you thinking about
and then what do we capture that then we
can add and turn into something that's
more
inspiring well just to let you know this
interview was really helpful for me and
uh yeah I really feel like a
Newman Great Well we fed the wolf for
one day it's great so he's given you
some Frameworks to work in right so Vlog
yourself do these assignments I gave you
a couple of assignments like we're going
to figure out how to reach out to these
people I want you to come on Thursday I
want you to come on Friday like we're
we're lining some things out but those
are just like boxes to play in but you
have to start playing in the box right
so if you're filming me at the event and
all of a sudden like you want to film
yourself for some reason like you got
this takeaway because I said something
that reminds you of your mom and you're
getting emotional and you like I should
film this great leave the room go
outside and film Evan just said this
thing and it reminds me my mom and y y
even though that's not the assignment
because that's where like all the great
stuff ends up being created right I say
something that makes you want to go do
400 push-ups cool like go outside turn
the camera on yourself and like you
start doing 400 doing right there in
front of the
like that's the creativity and freedom
that I'm that I want to see injected in
because that's where I think the magic
will happen instead of me or Anthony
just telling you what to do it's plain
so that it becomes it's our thing it's
not my thing or his thing it's our thing
together but it can only be our thing if
you're bringing something to it and your
bringing to it is not just press and
record on the camera and getting what
you're supposed to be getting right you
have to bring you have to inject some
heart into it but I can't tell you what
heart to inject in right that's you so
the ideas come it's like okay this might
be stupid and if if we lose the whole
day of filming because of it cool like
go do it one one uh big takeaway from
you right now once we finish all this is
like the courage to try and take action
that's the biggest sck away because most
of the time when something when I'm not
doing everything it's because that
carage to try is not that take for examp
like I'm feeling like okay if I do if
I'm doing this right now I'm doing too
much say I'm trying to do I'm even
sometimes I'm in a commercial gym and I
definitely feel like I'm better than all
these people in the things I want to do
or I want to do a a pullup then I like
oh I can do 30 pull-ups right now I'm
doing all these things but then I be
like oh my God I'm doing too much then I
stop
myself because I'm feeling like I'm
feeling like hey I don't want to
intimidate all these people but that's
the courage it's not there so everything
we've done today has giving me that
thing now like hey I can do this and
even if everybody doesn't like it
there's at least going to be somebody
there that were like wow I like that and
that's more than enough you know to
continue to keep trying because not
everybody's not going to not everybody's
going to like what you're doing well
listen you're you're now stepping in
it's you're stepping into an opposite
world right when you go to a gym and
you're better than everyone else you're
you're able to do way more than anybody
else at the gym you're stepping into a
new world where you're not the best like
you're the worst like you're coming into
group of entrepreneurs who are paying
tens of thousands of dollars to be here
flying from around the world like
entrepreneur wise you're the worsts
facts but it's not about being best at
worst you still have an idea and I want
to see that idea yes yes so even it my
it might end up being a not good idea or
stupid idea or may not work out I just
want you to start exercising the muscle
yeah yeah because you have to through
this process bring your heart you have
to contribute something to the recipe
right like we're giving you the bowls
and the ingredients but you have to add
something to the recipe as well MH
instead of just doing what kind of what
cuz you could do you could do a great
job of us telling you what to do and I
don't know if anthon would give you a
passing grade but like you're going to
fail in my books if you just do what I
tell you to do that's not what you're
here I could hire somebody to come and
just film me right I need you to inject
some art into it I need to see bits of
you so why I want you to do it
separately cuz I need you to trust in
your own ideas and skill and art and
love and passion and pour that in cuz
together we can make something this is
why they choose specific directors to
direct certain types of film because
they inject a certain amount of their
own personality into the film that
nobody else can do yeah so that's what
you guys have to be thinking about when
you're thinking about creating what can
I inject into this that nobody else can
because I'm doing this and that's the
best part of working with me is that I'm
I I'll roll with it
right you want to sit down and do an
interview and talk about something cool
you want me to Mentor Alex or you I want
to work with you and you're might be
your vision ends up being completely
different than his as long as ultimately
the goal is to elevate people inspire
people like I'm not going to come
and uh spew some hate on somebody right
like I'm not going to do that but almost
anything else as long as the intention
is positive you see something in Spike
Lee that he does some special Zoom in or
zoom out effect or whatever it's like
Evan I want you to do this like okay
let's go what are we doing I want you to
walk around the thing and I'm going to
I'm gonna I'm going to sit on Alex's
shoulders and he's going to piggyback me
as I cool let's go am I doing it right
am I right let's do it I'm happy to do
that right because you see something and
it may end up totally failing and you
forgot the press record or whatever cool
all right next tomorrow we're going to
do something else yeah right but that's
the kind of stuff that I want to see so
I like we're we have to all be in this
making something together can't just be
me and anthy and even Anthony needs to
like I want him to step up in this
process too I'm thinking about how to
tell your stories better okay you ready
for a fun six months for sure always all
right anything else you guys want to add
anybody Alex you want to share anything
no I'm good you got any advice for these
actually yes give him a microphone
introduce hold on yeah Alex get in get
in here Alex Alex is like counting the
clock cuz he's got to go or he's got
people coming here so we need to stretch
this longer just to make him even more
nervous
thank yeah all right okay coming come in
here make sure he's in in our perfect
shot how long have we been working with
you uh nine years now nine years okay oh
my gosh nine years a lot long a lot of
mentorship yeah is it paying
off it's it's an understatement to say
you've changed my life okay so great so
these guys are getting started they're
about to spend six months what advice do
you have for them in working with me uh
come early that's true who was the
earliest one here uh oh they all came
together they came at the same time
right yeah that's true okay uh come
early don't be loud don't be in the way
um come with a lot of energy and
enthusiasm um you can always learn
something even if it's not something
you're learning about so the reason I'm
here is because I wanted to hear how
Evan interviews you how he coaches you
when you ask these questions how he
navigates I want to be a better lead
so I might not do anything with the film
knowledge but I'm doing a lot with how
he's interacting with you so there's
always room to learn a lot um Tech stuff
anything like on the logistics side like
anything that's extra it's never the
thing you're always the the thing you're
the person so don't overly heavily rely
on your Tech to tell the story um ask
lots of questions as much as you can I
think I've gotten better at asking just
better questions a lot of my questions
back then were were just really really
really bad um and uh I mean I there's so
much okay and what was your takea away
from all
this um from this uh plant the seeds
earlier uh listen to your gut so uh I
had I haven't didn't have an interaction
with you yet but I had an interaction
with you and when we were walking out I
was like I love this kid yeah he did say
that he did say that yeah legit legit
and it's just like we getting coffee
he's like I don't know about these other
guys but I like
Tito he did no I did I did legit legit
yeah yeah yeah yeah because I'm all
about Vibes so but so you haven't talked
to I haven't I haven't talked to yet but
you did talk to these these punks over
here uh no I haven't talked no I talked
to so you only talked to him I only
talked to him and he approached yeah it
was just Good Vibes approached me
started talking and uh he yeah and he
was very vulnerable and open okay he
right away said about him traveling
around and blah blah blah and all this
and I'm like I like this guy like hard
on the has pretty high standards yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I was I was like I
was like is there a way I can make him a
danc instructor in my school that's that
was my next thought like legit listen
I'm like coaching Talent yeah 100%
100% with you the thing that today that
stood out was uh when you were
challenging David goggin I've been I've
read all his books I've been consuming
his content uh David goggin I think will
crush you to be honest uh and it has
nothing to do with age it's just he's
going to want it more than you and and
it's something I aspire to it's not even
disrespect to you like I am I am the guy
who sat on the toilet on nine gag so I'm
like for an hour and a half my gosh yeah
yeah yeah my left foot would always fall
asleep I still remember that which makes
me angry but the fact that that you want
to set that bar also made me smile and
it reminded me to to continue to be
hungry um so that that really made me
happy when you were when you were
thinking that and imagine how you'll get
crushed in that but more importantly um
what else did I learn um I mean I took a
ton of notes to be honest but he's
looking at he's like his he's he's he's
like I'm gonna show this guy let's go
let's go make him dance make him dance
right let's go but like but but um uh
there there's a ton more the way that
you guided them and direct like it was
interesting like only the end of this
interview was here's how to best work
with me and it's just a lesson for me of
a lot of times when I when I approach
the new Talent a future instructors I
would tend to avoid that and so you were
very canat like here are my strengths
and so when I'm interviewing for my
dance school I should tell them like
this is what works really well in the
school and so unlike Evan I'm not that
flexible in how I want the structure of
the school to be but I also know my
strengths like um so anyway so there was
that that that's important don't be
afraid to say this is this is what will
work best with me as we get to work
together and just giving those
expectations and letting people be like
I love this or not a ton of other stuff
to be honest I I get to go through my
notes but every time I'm around I'm I'm
just thinking I know nothing learn more
I know nothing learn more yeah all right
thank you man appreciate all right thank
you guys
well season uh season 1 episode one this
is it thank you guys great to meet you
looking forward to working with you
thanks much love to see me coaching
another entrepreneur one-on-one check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there do you want to make
money in the next 30 days then you start
a bis Dev show so let's use a business
as an example okay let's say
architectural firm so let's say it's a a
company here in Toronto if you already
have an existing business and you
already know your ideal referral lead
sources